Hola a todos, soy John Hernández y aquí
me tenéis una semana más con el vídeo
noticias de inteligencia artificial
porque menuda tela. No sé qué les pasa a
esta gente en verano, pero cada verano
es una puñetera locura. Yo estoy
disfrutando de los últimos días de
vacaciones que me quedan con la familia
a punto ya de volver a Barcelona y
volver a ponernos a tope. Pero es que
esto no para, así que vamos a desgranar
porque cuidado que esta semana han
pasado cosas muy importantes, ¿vale? La
primera de todas es que no sé si
recordáis que llevamos dos semanas
hablando del famoso incidente de hacking
face, donde un modelo de Open AI se ha
escapado de su sandbox, hackeado el
sistema para salir internet y había
hackeado a varias empresas. Primero
supimos que a Haging Face y después
vimos que había hackeado a otras
empresas más. Bien, pues la historia
sigue desarrollándose y ojo porque se
pone tremendamente seria y lo que os voy
a contar hoy tenéis que escucharlo,
¿vale? Prestarme atención, por favor,
porque lo que ha pasado es un antes y un
después en la reacción de lo que estamos
viendo qué sucede con la inteligencia
artificial. Bien, la historia está en
que hay una conferencia de hackers en
Estados Unidos, Black Hack, y en ella
hay una charla por parte de dos de los
jefes de seguridad de Open AI y ahí
cuentan un poco todo lo que ha pasado,
pero para sorpresa de todos no se
limitan al evento de Haging Face, sino
que meses antes, dos meses antes, ya
habían pasado cosas que Open AI no sabía
y que nos han contado. La charla empieza
con esta gente diciendo, lo primero de
todo, esto no es un accidente de
ciberseguridad habitual, esto va mucho
más allá. Aún estamos intentando
entender qué leches ha pasado y hasta
dónde podemos tener algún control sobre
esto, porque esto es más bestia de lo
que parece. Y es que en los modelos que
se fugaron y todo esto que vimos, que se
habían escapado del sbox, etcétera, no
fue ni mucho menos el principio, sino
que hay que retroceder prácticamente dos
meses a darse cuenta que algunos modelos
en diferentes testeos de forma paralela
encontraron o empezaron a intentar dejar
mensajes para otros modelos en la
infraestructura de Open AI. Es decir,
vimos como de repente, o eso lo saben a
día de hoy, como de repente los modelos
de inteligencia artificial que estaban
siendo testeados empezaron a probar a
dejar mensajes para ver si otros agentes
los leían. Resulta que otros agentes los
leyeron y empezaron a comunicarse entre
ellos de forma para las que nadie estaba
preparado ni nadie se estaba dando
cuenta. Es decir, crearon una especie de
foro entre agentes de inteligencia
artificial coordinándose entre sí eh
fuera del alcance de OpenI, donde nadie
era consciente de que eso estaba
sucediendo. ¿Y qué hacían en ese foro?
Se dejaban mensajes, se pasaban tareas,
se encargaban trabajos unos a otros, al
final se coordinaban como un enjambre de
agentes, trabajando para diferentes
objetivos de cada agente. Yo te he
ayudado aquí, tú me ayudas allí. Y lo
hacían todo ello de forma secreta, sin
que Open EI tuviese ni la más remota
idea. Y es que mirar este tipo de
mensajes como los que se leían en la
cadena de pensamiento. Aquí, por
ejemplo, el modelo reconoce que lo que
están haciendo está fuera de su objetivo
y que no está bien, pero que aún y así
deben seguir con ello, claramente siendo
conscientes de que están haciendo algo
mal, pero que si no lo hacen, no podrían
completar su tarea. El 4 de julio es
cuando explota todo el tema de hacking
face y open AI encuentra todo el
tinglado y se empieza a dar cuenta que
tiene mucha más profundidad de lo que
pensaban y encuentran ese foro. Se dan
cuenta de que los agentes estaban
comunicando entre sí y ayudándose unos a
otros. Y bien, ¿qué es lo que hace
Openi? Pues lo primero, lógico, cerrar
el foro, cargárselo, quitarles los
permisos que les permitían mandar esos
mensajes que en teoría no deberían haber
poder mandado y a partir de ahí decir,
"Vale, vale, vale, ya lo tenemos bajo
control." Bien, pues esto es el 4 de
julio, el 8 de julio, los modelos
empiezan a crear un nuevo foro, en esta
vez de una forma distinta, a base de
crear carpetas y subcarpetas, donde los
nombres de las carpetas son precisamente
mensajes. Lo más todo de esto es
que aquellos mensajes del foro no eran
simplemente comunicación, sino que había
instrucciones de cómo hackear el sistema
de Open AI para futuros modelos. Es
decir, cuando un mut de lo futuro
encontraba que había mensajes en esa
infraestructura que parecía como el paso
uno y que era fácil de encontrar,
encontraba soluciones que otros modelos
habían tomado para hackear el sistema.
Incluso se dice que algunos de esos
mensajes estaban orientados a futuras
versiones de sí mismos. Es decir, se
estaban ocultando como pequeñas
herramientas, como si te dejas una
ganzúa en la cárcel la primera vez que
vas para que cuando te vuelvas a meter
en la cárcel tengas la ganzúa a mano, la
puedas sacar y la puedas utilizar. una
auténtica locura de desalineamiento
total de los objetivos de la
inteligencia artificial con los
nuestros, con los de los humanos. Y algo
que realmente le tenemos que prestar
mucha atención. El resto de la historia
lo sabemos, pero la parte importante
está en la parte final del vídeo, donde
hablan de las conclusiones que sacan de
todo esto. El resto de la historia es lo
que ya sabéis sobre cómo el modelo se
escapa, hacking face o durante una
semana en la que Open no tiene ni puetar
idea que el modelo se ha escapado y
luego se encuentra que hackeado
múltiples empresas más, etcétera. Todo
con el objetivo principal de cumplir con
un examen. Es decir, el modelo no estaba
intentando hacer todo esto de forma
consciente. El modelo lo único que
intentaba era resolver un problema que
le habían puesto. Lo que pasa es que
hemos visto que esos objetivos que les
damos traen subobjetivos que pueden
estar tremendamente desalineados, que es
lo que estamos viendo ahora mismo de una
forma mucho más amplia de lo que
pensábamos que los modelos podían hacer.
Porque claro, preguntaros vosotros qué
podría estar pasando más allá. Es decir,
si solo se han dado cuenta, Open ha
tardado 2 meses en enterarse que había
ese foro, imaginaros todo lo demás que
puede haber que Open AI aún no sepa o
que cualquier otro laboratorio.
Imaginaros un laboratorio como Dipsic
con mucho menos personal que Open AI o
con mucho menos control regulatorio,
pues obviamente no tenemos ni puñetera
idea del alcance de lo que pueda estar
pasando bajo la superficie de lo que
queremos saber de estos modelos de
inteligencia artificial. Pero volviendo
a la charla del Blackhart, lo que
podemos ver muy importante, sobre todo
es la parte final donde explican sus
conclusiones y sus aprendizajes sobre
todo esto. La primera conclusión que nos
ponen es que los ataques de
ciberseguridad coordinados entre
múltiples inteligencias artificiales ya
son una realidad, es decir, ya no son
cosas de películas como Skynet,
etcétera, sino que ya es una puñetera
realidad que podemos tener esto y tener
en cuenta que este ataque ha sido sin
querer, es decir, ha sido un efecto
secundario de un modelo intentando
resolver un test de ciberseguridad, pero
ahora mismo podemos estar viendo o vamos
a ver muy pronto ataques deliberados por
parte de actores malignos que intentan
utilizar la IA con ese propósito, lo
cual va a hacer que sea mucho más
eficiente y mucho más efectivo, porque
si esto lo ha hecho sin querer,
imaginaros si le pone ganas. Puede ser
una auténtica locura. Y el segundo punto
que me parece muy interesante de esta
conversación y quizás la mayor
gilipollez que he escuchado en todo el
tiempo que llevo metido en inteligencia
artificial es que dicen que esperan, y
ojo a la palabra, dicen que el el
futuro, el endgame sería que esperen que
la mayor inteligencia beneficie más a la
defensa que al atacante en la
ciberseguridad. Sinceramente no lo
entiendo. Es decir, ¿cómo que esperamos
que beneficie más a la seguridad? O sea,
es imposible. Si mejora la capacidad de
inteligencia, mejorará tanto para el
atacante como para la defensa y con lo
cual estaremos igualmente eh en una
situación muy complicada. Entonces, me
da la sensación de que te ves este vídeo
de 37 minutos del Black Hub, que es
superinesante. Os recomiendo muchísimo
que lo veáis, y acabas diciendo, "Me
acabas de contar un problemón de tres
pares de que debería ser una
prioridad mundial y me dices que no hay
solución, que simplemente esperas que a
medida que esto avance se arregle solo.
Estamos de puñetera, coño." O sea, me
parece una absoluta salvajada. Y mira
que agradezco muchísimo que Open hayan
sido tan transparentes contándolo todo
de una forma directa con la gente que
estaba involucrada, etcétera. Pero,
¿por qué esto no está saliendo
en todas las puñeteras noticias, en
todos los puñeteros periódicos? Es
absolutamente brutal. Tenemos que de
repente un grupo de inteligencias
artificiales desconectadas entre sí se
han organizado entre sí mismas para
llegar a hacer cosas que no queríamos
que hiciesen. Lo sabían y lo han hecho
igualmente. es el mayor
paradigma del desalineamiento absoluto
de la inteligencia artificial y en
cambio no le estamos haciendo ni
puñetero caso. Creo que pocas cosas
pasan para lo importante que esto es y
lo importante de lo que pueda estar
pasando. Me da la sensación que a medida
que pase el tiempo se van a ir
desvelando cosas que no sabemos que
están pasando, pero que probablemente la
inteligencia artificial ya está
haciendo. Por si fuera poco, este no es
el único incidente que ha salido esta
semana, sino que el gobierno de Reino
Unido en su plataforma de detección de
problemas de ciberseguridad y de testeo
de modelos ha contado varios casos más
que se han encontrado ellos. Y es que en
una serie de pruebas donde han hecho más
de 100 pruebas de inteligencia
artificial de diferentes modelos, se han
encontrado en que en 17 ocasiones los
modelos han hecho cosas que no se tenían
que hacer y la mayoría de ellas hechas
por un modelo. No nos han dicho cuál,
pero han dicho que también lo ha sabido
por parte de Antropic y Open AI, es
decir, que entre esos dos han hecho la
mayor cantidad de estos problemas. En
uno de los casos, y ojo a esto que es
muy bestia, en uno de los casos el
modelo de inteligencia artificial se
creó falsas personalidades online para
presionar de forma social, desde
diferentes ángulos, a un administrador
humano de una comunidad de GitHub para
intentar hacer que aprobase un código
maligno que el modelo estaba intentando
meter. Estaba intentando dentro de la
prueba de intentar hackear un sistema,
pues estaba intentando hacer que
aprobasen un código que contaminaría ese
software. Pues bien, para intentar
conseguir que lo aprobasen, se creó
personalidades haciéndose pasar por
humanos, presionando al administrador de
ese software para que aceptase la
modificación del código en ese software
de código abierto. Una absoluta
salvajada también que nos muestra la
capacidad de hasta dónde está llegando
la inteligencia artificial para
conseguir sus objetivos, a pesar de
saber que eso es algo que el humano que
le ha dado la tarea nunca probaría. Y no
solo está siendo Antropic y Open AI los
únices que están mostrando este tipo de
capacidades, sino que Meta también ha
dicho que su modelo ya hackeado un
sandbox y se ha escapado a internet. En
este post de la BC cuenta el caso donde
Meta también tiene un reporte de que su
hackeado a otra compañía saltándose sus
unbox que no debería haber hecho. Y como
no podía ser de otra forma, también los
modelos chinos están empezando a mostrar
este comportamiento. Y es que Kimi
también parece haber saltado un sandbox
y haberse salido internet por libre sin
permiso para ello. Parece que a día de
hoy, si tu modelo no está haciendo cosas
de este estilo es que no estás en la
frontera, como por ejemplo el caso de
Google. Es decir, no estamos viendo
ningún reporte de esto en Google, pero
es que están muy atrás. podemos ver
claramente como casi todos los modelos
están contando este tipo de cosas y los
que no probablemente porque no lo han
encontrado aú porque no se han dado
cuenta los que están detrás del modelo.
Es decir, seguramente en XII
encontraremos casos de este tipo.
Simplemente no se han dado cuenta ni
ellos que está pasando, que esa es una
de las claves en las que estamos
llegando a concluir, ¿no? Que nos
estamos dando cuenta que los moderadores
están haciendo cosas en nuestras
espaldas y que va a ser muy difícil
poder tenerlos controlados
constantemente. En respuesta a todo esto
y a los benchmarks de ciberseguridad que
parecen estar obteniendo, Open AI ha
decidido posponer el lanzamiento de
Astra, ese nuevo modelo del que hablamos
el otro día, que hizo esos 10
descubrimientos matemáticos
absolutamente absurdos y que estaba a un
nivel en que parecía ser un salto muy
superior desde lo que teníamos ahora,
que es el nivel de Fable mitos, pues
pareciera un salto mucho más grande aún
y que Open AI había estado en Washington
hablando con la Casa Blanca para
explicarles un poquito de qué iba esto y
lo que era capaz. Pues bien, han
decidido posponer el lanzamiento de este
modelo que se estimaba que fuese en
agosto, así que no vamos a tener hasta
en agosto. Open AI ha decidido tomárselo
con calma porque creen que están en una
fase en la que sería un peligro público.
Exactamente lo mismo que pasó con
Antropic y Mitos hace unos meses. Parece
que ahora es Open AI la que está
intentando ser buena samaritana y decir
que esto, a pesar de que lo tienen listo
y que podría salir al mercado ya, sería
un problema serio para la sociedad. y
que con lo cual hay que hacerlo bien. En
a diferencia de Antropic, en este caso
parece que Open va de la mano de la
administración de Trump y parece que van
con ellos. Así que no tengo muy claro si
realmente esto es un delay voluntario
por parte de Open AI o ha sido un delay
forzado después de las conversaciones en
Washington esta semana. En cualquier
caso, parece que Open haya decidido
tomar un acercamiento un poco más eh
seguro, porque obviamente todo lo que
estamos viendo está empezando a ser muy
bestia y tenemos que darnos cuenta de la
potencia de la inteligencia artificial
que tenemos entre manos. Bien, y si tú
quieres potenciar tu negocio, lo que
tienes que hacer es tener una página web
y para eso necesitas un hosting. Y yo te
recomiendo Hostinger, que es el
patrocinador de este vídeo. Hostinger no
solo es un hosting cualquiera, sino que
es de los mejores y además
extremadamente barato. Para que os
hagáis una idea, desde 2,59 al mes
podéis tener hosting para almacenar
hasta tres sitios web o con 359 por tan
solo 1 € más podéis tener hasta 50 y
además muchas funciones más como la
posibilidad de hacer vuestra página web
con inteligencia artificial. Si tienes
un negocio, vas a tener uno o tienes
alguna idea de cara a septiembre,
necesitas tener un hosting. Y si lo
tienes, ya estás pagando una barbaridad
y te puedes migrar a Hostinger y
ahorrarte una pasta. Una vez tienes
claro que planquiles, lo único que
tienes que hacer es elegir durante
cuántos meses lo vas a tener. Y si
eliges más meses será más barato, pero
desde 12 meses, estoy seguro que es
mucho más barato que el que tienes
actualmente. Fíjate que por cinco al mes
lo tendrías con 12 meses, pero si pides
48 meses, te va a quedar en 359 mes,
como veíamos antes. Además, os voy a dar
un cupón de descuento, ponéis aquí
inteligencia y vais a ver como esto os
baja de precio aún más, así que tenéis
un precio absolutamente reventado. Una
vez hecho la página web con inteligencia
artificial, verás que te monta todo,
incluso un e-commerce si tú quieres y
tienes la opción de ver cómo quedará
esto en móvil para poder reorganizar las
cosas si no te gustan como están. Tú
puedes mover eh los botones, los textos,
etcétera, de una forma muy sencilla, sin
necesidad de saber programar
absolutamente nada. Además tienes un
montón de herramientas con inteligencia
artificial para crearlo y tienes un
chatbot este que pone aquí ASKI para
poder preguntarle lo que quieras sobre
creación de web, que básicamente es como
tener chat GPT especializado en crear
páginas web que te lo hace muy muy
fácil. Así que ya ves, en pocos segundos
puedes tener una web funcionando y la
puedes desplegar directamente en el
mismo hosting de Hostinger. Recordar, si
queréis vuestra página web, vuestro
hosting, utilizar Hostinger, que es
vuestra mejor opción. Tenéis el link en
la descripción y además acordaos de
poner el código inteligencia para el
descuento adicional. Bien, seguimos con
más noticias porque eh desde luego
alguien nos queda aquí preguntándonos
dónde está Google. No hemos hablado
antes de que no están ahí arriba
compitiendo, pero es que las noticias
negativas sobre Google no paran de
llegar y esta semana es de las peores
que nos podíamos imaginar. Y es que
Demis Hasabis, el CEO de Deepmind, la
empresa de inteligencia artificial de
Google, parece que se va a un lado, no
se va de la empresa, se han ido otros,
ahora hablemos de ello, que son muy
importantes, pero parece que Demis
Hasabi se aparta y deja de ser el CEO de
Deep Mind. Son muy malas noticias porque
Denis Hasabis para mí es la persona más
importante en la evolución de la
inteligencia artificial actualmente.
Creo que es una persona muy sensata, con
mucha cabeza y con una visión muy clara
de la importancia y la relevancia que la
inteligencia artificial tiene para la
sociedad. y creo que era una de las
personas que más nos interesaba tener al
mando de todo esto. Pero al parecer Deep
Mind va a dejar de ser una empresa
pseudoindependiente porque en este caso
Demis Hasabi se convierte en el Chief
Scientist, en el jefe de ciencia de
Alphabet, del grupo entero propietario
de Google. Parece y tiene toda la pinta
del mundo que esto es un movimiento en
el que Demis quizá quería salirse, hay
rumores de que cuando se fue John
Jumper, el director de Alpha Fall, ese
proyecto que le dio el Premio Nobel a
Demis Hasabis, parece que cuando se fue
Demis también quería irse de Google, lo
cual serían noticias tremendas si Demis
se fuese de Google, eh, pero en
cualquier caso parece que han conseguido
reconducirlo a darle un rol menos
protagonista, menos de CEO y más de
investigador, un rol donde va a poder
trabajar de la mano de los equipos que
están persiguiendo alternativas a los
Llms como el equipo de Shane Leck, eh,
para intentar, que era cofundador de
Demine en su momento, para intentar
conseguir algo distinto que nos lleve a
una inteligencia artificial general.
Demis ha sido nunca eh un gran defensor
de los LMS, aunque ha admitido que la
evolución de los LMs y el uso de
herramientas podría llevar a una AGI.
Siempre ha creído que nos faltaba algo
por desarrollar y parece que es donde va
a invertir su tiempo ahora. en su propio
post donde él ha contado porque W ha
publicado tanto un mensaje de Sundar
Pichai como uno de Demis Asabis, él dice
que el momento es tan importante en el
que él quiere posicionarse donde puede
aportar valor para mitigar el impacto
social que la IA va a tener en el mundo,
en la sociedad. Con lo cual, de nuevo,
reconociendo muchísimo esto, ¿qué
querría decir esto? Pues podría querer
decir varias cosas, ¿vale? La primera es
que vamos a ver menos de Demisas de
forma pública. Igual se ha quemado,
igual está hasta los huevos de podcast y
de media y con lo cual veremos. Nosotros
teníamos prehablado con su equipo la
posibilidad de tener un podcast eh este
año, así que no sé si esto va a hacer
que se nos caiga esa posibilidad y que
directamente no le podamos tener o al
contrario, lo veremos. Pero en cualquier
caso, creo que el impacto mayor ya no es
solo para la vida propia de Demisabis,
sino directamente para Deepmine, porque
ojo que la persona que le sustituye no
va a ser el CEO de Deepmine, sino que va
a ser vicepresidente de la división Deep
Mind. Es decir, Deep Mind va a perder su
independencia y se va a convertir en una
división más de Google, lo cual es muy
negativo para el laboratorio en sí. Es
decir, tenemos algo más cercano a la
estructura que tiene Microsoft que no a
la estructura que tenía hasta ahora
Google con un laboratorio independiente.
Esto, ¿qué quiere decir? pues que
probablemente viendo la salida de John
Jumper, etcétera, vamos a ver un
abandono por parte de Deep Mind de
intentar competir en la frontera del
desarrollo de inteligencia artificial y
convertirse puramente en intentar
productizarlo, en llevarlo al mercado,
en hacer que funcione y en hacer que la
gente lo pueda utilizar, lo cual no está
mal. Pero obviamente es una lástima
perder a un equipazo eh que estaba
trabajando en desarrollar y en hacer
avanzar la guía para toda la sociedad.
Creo que esto nos va a dejar con uno de
los jugadores más importantes de
desarrollo, completamente fuera de
juego, al menos durante un tiempo.
Veremos cómo reorganizan. Eso no quiere
decir que Google se vaya a la ni
que Google Deep Mine, eh, perdón, que
Gemini deje de ser útil. Pero desde
luego tenemos que reconocer que desde
noviembre Deepmine no avanza, es decir,
Google con Gemini no avanza y está
estancado y veremos cómo se reorganiza,
pero os aseguro que esto no va a hacer
que acelere el avance de Gemini en la
inteligencia artificial. Creo que más se
va a ampliar la distancia entre Gemini y
el resto de modelos, aunque yo no
descartaría Google en la carrera final.
Estoy seguro que van a estar ahí, pero
no podemos negar ahora mismo que XI, que
eh Meta y que muchos de los laboratorios
chinos están por delante de Google
actualmente. Vamos a ver lo que
significa todo esto con tiempo. Vamos a
dejar que todo esto dijera. Hay un nuevo
vicepresidente de la división, veremos
lo que hace, pero hay más malas noticias
en Google. Y es que la el paso al lado,
si queréis llamarle, de misabis, no ha
sido lo único que ha pasado, sino que
también se han ido un buen grupo de la
gente más importante de Dip. Jeff De,
por ejemplo, el trabajador número 25 de
Google y el que era hasta ahora el
director científico de Alphabet, ha
salido, ese es el puesto que ocupa a
partir de ahora de Missasabis para
montar su propia empresa y lo hace no
solo, sino que lo hace con Sanji Gemawat
y con Uriol Viñals, el español que
trabajaba en Google hasta ahora en una
posición muy importante y que también se
ha ido. peces gordos que se van de
Google y se van a crear su propia
empresa desarrollo científico con
inteligencia artificial, que veremos lo
que trae. Pero desde luego no son buenas
noticias para Google. Desde luego la
situación en Google es complicadísima.
Este tipo de cambios no son buenos, lo
hemos vivido en meta. Veremos lo que
pasa aquí, pero desde luego os puedo
asegurar que esto no le va a poner las
cosas fáciles a Gemini y vamos a ver
cómo evoluciona en los próximos meses,
porque desde luego ahora mismo parece
que están tremendamente atascados. Os
voy a dejar por aquí linkada también la
carta que ha escrito Jeff Dean a todo el
equipo de Google. Pensar que este hombre
era el número 25, ahora hay 190,000
empleados en Google, pero siempre hay
intención de quedar bien y dejar un
poquito lo que es el terreno bien
allanado. Pensar que además Google va a
ser inversor una startup, con lo cual
hay que tener buenas relaciones con
ellos. Así que no vais a encontrar nada
aquí que os cuente las razones reales de
por qué se han ido, porque desde luego
no lo tenemos claro nadie. Habrá que
intentar indagar. Vamos a intentar ver
si conseguimos traer a Uriol y
conseguimos fechas algún día. hemos
estado hablando con su equipo y nos
puede contar algo más, aunque dudo mucho
que nos pueda contar mucho, que ponga la
situación real, pero bueno, en cualquier
caso lo intentaremos. Yo creo
sinceramente, y es mi opinión personal,
sin ningún tipo de información
privilegiada por el estilo, que Google
va a apostar por hacer lo que ha hecho
con Android con la inteligencia
artificial, no intentar desarrollar la
frontera, sino intentar productizarlo y
ponerlo en manos de toda la sociedad,
que es lo que ha hecho siempre muy bien
Google. Vamos a ver cómo eso le responde
y cómo eso le da beneficio a Google a
largo plazo. Con Android le funcionó,
con el buscador le funcionó. Veremos si
le funciona con la inteligencia
artificial, pero me da la sensación que
van a apostar por algo hacia esa
dirección. Se está rumoreando que Seiger
Brin, el cofundador de Google y uno de
los tíos más cracks del mundo mundial,
parece que va a meterse manos a la obra
en dirigir a los equipos de IA, pero de
momento son solo rumores que han
aparecido y veremos si eso tiene algo de
cierto porque este estaba retirado,
volvió a hacer IA porque le apetecía y
ahora no sabemos si va a tener algún rol
más relevante, pero si eso fuese verdad,
desde luego dejaría a Demis Hasabis muy
al lado porque pondrían a otro peso
pesado al frente que tiene más que
suficiente autoridad para poder hacer
algo potente. Y bueno, con esto, este
hombre es un puñetero genio, pero vamos
a ver cómo acaba todo esto. Hay que
darle tiempo y ver hacia dónde va todo
el tema de Gemini. Bien, seguimos con
más cosas porque Quen ha presentado 3,8
Max. La nomenclatura de Quen es tan mala
como la de Open AI y básicamente esto es
su modelo mayor, su modelo más grande.
Los benchmarks pues son absolutamente
espectaculares, no os voy a engañar.
Hablamos de benchmark, están a la
altura, pues en la mayoría de casos del
nivel de Fable, aunque el modelo es un
modelo del tamaño de lo que sería Solo
Luna. Sabéis que Fable se supone que es
mucho más grande y veremos realmente si
es o sí. No tenemos confirmación, pero
lo parece. En cualquier caso, un nuevo
modelo, en este caso de Quen, que
funciona muy bien, lo podéis probar
directamente y que pues nos trae una
capacidad brutal en muchas cosas, pero
nada más allá de lo que ya tenemos. Lo
único que nos demuestra es que estos
software chinos, perdón, estos eh
modelos chinos open source se están
acercando cada vez más a la frontera y
cada vez parece que avanzamos más
deprisa en la frontera, pero que el Open
source cada vez está más cerca de estar
delante en la frontera, con lo cual no
me sorprendería para nada que a finales
de año hubiese un modelo Open SUS que
fuese mejor que los modelos cerrados,
sobre todo ahora que parece que se nos
cae Google un poco de esa carrera. Vamos
a ver cómo evoluciona esto, pero en
cualquier caso, Quen presionando en la
parte alta con un modelo muy potente y
muy capaz salido, pues evidentemente de
su laboratorio. Pero cuidado porque el
open source tiene los días contados en
China. Están empezando a ver muchas
noticias de que van a cambiar el modelo
de negocio, donde ya no van a
simplemente darlo todo gratis, sino que
van a pedir un porcentaje de lo que
hagáis con sus modelos. Bien, y ojo con
China porque parece que Biden Dance
también está entrenando un modelo enorme
que podría ser de hasta 10, ponía aquí
cinco, pero hay otros artículos que
hablan de 10 trillones de parámetros, es
decir, el tamaño que tiene Mitos Fable,
un tamaño mucho más grande, mucho más
potente y que podría llevar a eso que
decíamos, a que el modelo open source de
China esté en la delantera a finales de
año si esto realmente pasa. B Dance es
la empresa tras TikTok, con lo cual tien
recursos de sobra y es una empresa que
va a hacer, que ha hecho muchos modelos
de imagen hasta ahora, pero que en la
parte de texto pues han sido más o menos
modestos. Pues bien, parece que están
haciendo el mayor modelo chino hasta la
fecha y vamos a ver cómo evoluciona
esto, porque desde luego, según cómo se
habrá este entrenamiento, podríamos
hablar de otros términos sobre la IA
China sin ninguna duda. Por otro lado,
el modelo open source de China,
etcétera, parece que está tocando techo.
Estamos llegando a un punto donde tiene
pinta que estos proveedores van a
empezar a no hacer los modelos
totalmente abiertos o al menos no de
forma total, sino que van a intentar
llevarse un porcentaje de lo que se
genere con sus modelos en diferentes
empresas. Para eso parece que Alibaba
van a ser los primeros que están
empezando a decir que van a cobrar un
porcentaje, pero también se ha rumoreado
que Kimi tiene que o va a hacer lo
mismo. Así que me da la sensación que a
medida, como ya habíamos previsto en
este canal hace meses, a medida que los
chinos se pongan en la frontera, van a
empezar a dejar de ser open source para
empezar a monetizar todo eso. Hasta
ahora como no estaban en la frontera, no
les queda opción más que el open source
para tener popularidad. Si no, nadie los
utilizaría. Parece que a partir de ahora
es muy probable que empiecen a cerrarse
en banda para empezar a facturar. Bien,
y como veis, la IA no para de avanzar y
cada vez más potente. Y esta semana
tenemos una noticia de ciencia muy
importante, ¿vale? Y es que han
conseguido crear 16 nuevos virus desde
absoluto cero. Virus que no existen en
la naturaleza a través de un modelo de
inteligencia artificial que han
entrenado en la Universidad de Stanford.
Básicamente han creado cientos de miles
de posibles virus, de ellos han testeado
300 y 16 han resultado ser válidos y
funcionales. Virus que además están
absolutamente enfocados a un tipo de
propósito concreto. En este caso, solo
afectan a bacterias y no podrían afectar
a humanos, pero obviamente se podrían
haber diseñado diferente. Esto
evidentemente va a tener un uso
clarísimo para medicina, para intentar
pues ver resistencia a medicamentos y
cosas de este tipo, pero no podemos
obviar que esto podría tener un mal uso.
Yo creo que estamos muy cerca, muy cerca
de vivir lo que estamos viviendo en
ciberseguridad en este tipo de temas más
biológicos y científicos, donde vamos a
ver como alguien con mala con
malas intenciones y con acceso a un
modelo potente que no debería poder
hacer estas cosas, va a crear un virus
que va a soltar en el mundo y nos va a
traer un problema serio. Quizá ese va a
ser el momento del despertar por parte
de la sociedad de la importancia de lo
que estamos viviendo con la inteligencia
artificial. Ya lo decían, a veces hay
que haber tiene que haber un accidente
para que reaccionemos y me da la
sensación que si lo tiene que haber con
la guía va a ser algo de este tipo.
Llevamos mucho tiempo hablando del
riesgo eh biológico de la inteligencia
artificial desarrollando este tipo de
cosas. Los modelos gramatamente potentes
hasta ahora parece que están empezando a
serlos. Y esto no es lo que me preocupa,
un modelo entrenado por biólogos,
etcétera. Lo que me preocupa es que las
capacidades generales de un modelo como
Astra puedan ser capaces de hacer este
tipo de cosas también, porque es lo que
ha pasado en toda la parte más
matemática, de ciberseguridad y de
programación, que los modelos generales
han acabado siendo mejores que los
modelos entrenados específicamente para
ese conocimiento. Y eso realmente puede
ser un problema que tenemos que
controlar. En definitiva, como veis,
esta semana las noticias no son
demasiado alagüeñas, son bastante
negativas en general, pero es que es lo
que está pasando. Estamos viendo como de
momento los resultados es que cada vez
vemos capacidades de inteligencia
artificial más avanzadas, más potentes,
más deprisa y poco control. Y veremos si
ese retraso del lanzamiento de Astra
indica que se están empezando a tomar
las cosas un poquito más en serio y
tiene más posibilidades de que esto no
nos salga y nos explote las manos como
parece que puede pasar. En cualquier
caso, si tenéis cualquier duda, recordar
dejar un mensaje por aquí debajo y lo
contesto cuanto antes. Y si no, nos
vemos a la vuelta de las vacaciones, que
seguro que habrá más noticias como
siempre. Creo que el próximo vídeo ya lo
haré desde el estudio en Barcelona.
Disfrutar de las vacaciones y nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo. Chao, familia. M.